chairman you're back live streaming i
think yeah
um
are there any declarations of interest
that need to be
recorded no right well follow on then um
during the proceeding
the applicant and any
um
persons wishing to speak will be given
15 minutes
um the interesting part is you have 15
minutes between you
to make your submissions
um
and that includes any cross-examinations
you have of any witnesses
at the end of the earring you will all
be the applicant will be given and the
industry part will give them two minutes
to make um a closing speech
so can we start with uh our latin
apologies chairman uh we have to um ask
because of the technical problems
earlier um ask amber to introduce
herself and whether she has any
right okay sorry yes
um hello my name is amber whiting i live
at 290 little lakering
um and
in the village
okay thank you
can we carry on there with the licensing
licensing officer
chairman yes you can carry on with the
agenda thank you
good morning this is a application in
relation to a premises license made
under section 17 of the licensing act
2003
the application must be determined in
five working days of the conclusion of
the hearing in accordance with paragraph
26 of the licensing act hearings
regulations of 2005.
application was submitted to the
licensing authority by paula causa and
refers to the premises to be known as
hops off license 68 little wakering road
in little raking essex ss3
o j h and appendix a is a copy of the
original application that was submitted
the premises to which the application
relates comprise of retail premises with
the intention to operate as an off
licence
the premises is located within a small
parade of shops and that was included a
map of appendix b outlines the location
the application is for licensable
activities within the times and dates
which is the supply and sell of alcohol
off the premises only
and this is between monday and sunday
between 11 a.m and 11 p.m
the application was made in accordance
with section 17 of paragraph 7 of the
licensing act
and the
licensing acts 2003
regulations of 2005.
the only other licensed premises within
close proximity of the applicant
is the castle in public house
which i have included within the report
in relation to representations
under the responsible authorities the
police and invite um the police have
confirmed that they've made no
representation against the application
but have agreed conditions with the
applicant and a copy of those
conditions are attached as appendix d
in the document
the application was assessed by
environmental health and they have made
no representations against the
application
in relation to other persons there was
14 representations received from local
residents
six of those did not constitute as a
valid representation as these did not
relate to the licensing objectives as
outlined within the licensing act 2003
out of the eight
objections that were valid
they made representations against the
prevention of public nuisance and the
prevention of crime and disorder
objectives
and appendix e was a copy of their
relevant representations
in relation to notices all parties
involved have been served with the
relevant notices and documentation
required by paragraph six and seven of
the licensing act hearings regulations
of 2005.
i'm going to jump to the
point eight of the report is proposed
that the subcommittee results that the
application be determined according to
one of the following options
to grant the application subject to such
conditions that are consistent with the
operating schedule
modified to such extent as members
consider necessary for the promotion of
the licensing objectives and any
mandatory conditions must be included
or
to exclude from the scope of the license
any licensable activities to which the
application relates
to reject the application
or finally subjects to paragraphs 11 to
13 of the licensing acts 2003 hearings
regulations 2005 to adjourn the hearing
to a specified date or arrange for a
hearing to be held on specific
additional dates where members may
consider it necessary for the
consideration of any representations or
notice made by any party and that's the
end of the report
thank you serena right i have the
subcommittee
i've got any questions to ask mr greener
there are no hands up chairman thank you
and as any but any other party's got any
uh
clarification they need from mr greener
i can't see anybody so i should
i shall pass on then to the applicant if
she can um
make her submission please paula carson
um
i don't really understand what did you
want me to say sorry
well it it's um
obviously you're making this application
um the reason you know
what you wish to tell us
why you're making the application and
what have you in in the application
okay um at the moment i have a small
sandwich bar cat in the shop that
um i want to just like change usage to a
off license
um
because i've
not
have a limited um football there
um i've not made any money um i was it's
an a1 license so there's a limited also
what you can put in to the shop
and there's a there's been a beauty
parlor
flores pet shop electrical shop travel
agent
a few of my customers local customers
suggested the off license because there
isn't any in the awakening
um
which i thought was a good idea and also
there's nowhere in the awakening or
violin the cells off like um
off-premises alcohol
um
yes
that's probably yeah that's the reason i
wanted to do nothing license and just a
few locals had sort of suggested it to
me and
and also to make a living i've tried you
know there's a lot of shops that have
been there that's found
including mine and
yeah that's it i just want to do a
small off license
to sell off like off-premises alcohol
um
i probably won't do it 11 to 11. that
was um
the range of hours that i've prepared
okay right hey thank you or wilder i'll
ask any of the subcommittee if they've
got any questions they'd
like to ask at the moment okay
so i'm here
okay james
[Music]
good morning paula
my question to you is if you're making
this change
what um
what have you got in place for staff
training etc to deal with the sale of
alcohol i mean it is um you know
it's not a normal sun it is different to
probably what you've been selling what
have you what ideas have you got in plan
to your staff to identify potential
problems potential hazards
and how would you intend to deal with
that
paula you're on mute
i'm sorry
um yeah i'll be the only person working
there
um
[Music]
if
at any time i do want to employ
anyone i would probably ask them to do
their license course as well um
i have a high field level two for
underage sales prevention
and so i'm aware of like challenge 25
um
i've got lots of things
and security i'm going to have cctv
um security lights
motion sensors i've been asked by the
police to have one month video record on
the cctv
i also live opposite my the shop
which i also have cctv on my house which
all four shops are in clear view
and also
it be in my view 24 hours a day the shop
so it's sort of extra security there
i'm thinking of having shutters put on
the shock
um
there's only one entrance
at the front of the shop there is no
back
um
entrances or windows at the rear of the
shop or the side of the shop
so the only entrance is in view of the
road and
um
my home address
um
i've been asked by the police to record
any sound reviews refusals
any crime or disorder
any 40 cctv
um
[Music]
i won't be selling to
intoxicated people
okay i've challenged 25 signs up at the
shop um
under 18 signs up at the shop
um
around the shop there's no public areas
in close finitely here there's
no benches
there's really nowhere for anyone to
hang out not only that there is no
reason for anyone to hang out there's no
clubs or bars as you know there's
the castle which is
um like five minutes walk a couple of
minutes walk down the road
um
well there's loads
the ticket cleaners have been outside
the shop
there's have been opposite the shop
there's been a haven side the next road
down
um
okay can i stop yeah i think that we've
clarified
i think you've covered most things so
yeah
i think yeah there's also
um i know a lot of people were worried
about cars but i think that i would
probably
there'd be a lot less traffic because
i'd be walking distance to all the
locals around little wakerim
um there'd be no reason for them to get
in the car to drive to the co-op
because i you know they can walk there
which is
more economical for people and just
easier
can i just close the door
if you commute to your microphone
and so my um
raised hand was in regards to um a
concern rather than a um
clarification sorry about that i didn't
[Music]
when we go through your submissions
does anybody else um
no right okay we've got no uh authority
submissions so interested parties as i
say you've got 15 minutes in total um so
can we have a clarification
sorry
oh yeah um do you mean i i couldn't hear
what you just what your last few certain
sentences because of the dog parking
what did you ask about to the field
about cars i i propose there'd be less
car traffic because of being local
and people won't have to drive to the
co-op or to
um
mix the premiere
that
i'm being close proximity to
little awakens so
yeah i think there'd be less car traffic
less traffic on the road
so
can i ask a question or concern about
that
yeah
um
so obviously in the evening cars are
parked outside the front of the shop
this is probably one for the council as
much as you
um and people will drive to um to pick
up
stuff from an off licence obviously and
we have been in touch with the council
before
because what people tend to do is use
the widened pathway
to the front of the shops
and to cruise across to the um shop
front which runs directly
on the pavement so people basically
drive along the pavement
to
go through a gap that exists because of
a white line outside our house to get to
the shops
um we have been in touch with the
council before about putting a bollard
out to prevent that because we feel that
it's it's
it's a it's a health and safety issue
well we'll come to that as we go through
the the application right so as i say
yourself sorry one more thing i also
don't feel it's i also don't like the
idea that um paula is videoing me uh on
the other side of the parade from that
game
can we bring that up
you've got your submission now we can
bring anything you've got there and then
we can go through it and as i say you've
got 15 minutes between yourselves and
amber
so
i don't know who wants to go first
we'll see you on if you go first and
then carry on yeah i'll give you um
notice when
near the time i'll give you a minute
before the end
yeah so our main concerns um about the
application are um opinion hours
um paul you're not quite sure when
you're going to open but we feel that
it's uh it's a rural
location um there's
um
residential above you there's a
residential beside you and there's
residential obviously us we used to be a
shop we didn't convert the shops
ourselves and it was converted and given
planning permission by the council
uh five years before we bought the house
but um being in
the connected parade
um obviously sound does travel up and
down
the facade we can hear roller shutters
opening
we hear um for instance the council uh
arrived this morning to empty a bin
which is close to the location and they
regularly leave the van running whilst
they do that and in fact they were there
for five or six minutes this morning
having telephone calls outside the
refuse van
and all the time
um the engine's running
um so obviously we're awoken
six in the morning generally speaking
because papers are delivered
um
[Music]
to another premises in the parade uh
there's refuse being collected and
like i say we also have concerns because
it's quite a white pavement to the front
um of the shops and people do use it as
a kind of a launch area if there's cars
parked
in the road in front of the parade
and so people generally just speed along
the pavement to get to the front of the
shots
which is another concern
uh we all just go back to the noise as
well quickly because we accept we bought
the house next to the shops we we like
the shops we use the shops my son goes
and get what was when it was opened
stuff from paula and it's just we're
used to it being open at a certain time
and then shut in the evenings we're very
concerned about it being open in later
into the evenings slamming doors people
talking shouting
um you know it is a quiet rural road
there is hardly any lighting out there
really um
in fact there's no street lighting um
close to the shops at all if you were to
go out there of an evening it is pitch
black
and so another concern about is like the
light pollution and will there be an
illuminated fascia because from what we
know there won't be allowed to be one so
the chop's going to be in darkness at
night apart from the light on in the
shot
um
it just seems that
it's not appropriate in this quiet
removal location to have
a shop open until 11 p.m and i know
paula says she might not but she might
she might move on and sell her business
and someone else might come in and open
it to 11. we just don't want that
precedent set and for our peaceful life
to be um you know almost uh 24 7
and so to speak we it's not that we
don't want the shops eggs we do it's
just
at times we've also got other concerns
we've been woken at night on several
occasions um number 64 next door was
broken into the doors were smashed open
and the till
was burgled
um the shop next door that one
which um is 16
uh it's 64a because it used to be an
alleyway alleyway through
um to the back of the shots but then was
filled in and made into a shot that was
broken into
and cigarettes etc stolen
um
the uh village store um has also had an
attentive break-in to the rear
um which was ineffectual because there's
a roller shutter behind there we believe
um
so yeah there's been various occasions
when crime has definitely taken place in
the parade um
which is
namely you know due to
trying to steal cigarettes trying to get
cash out of the
teals
etc
um so i i'm a bit i'm not sure if the
police have mentioned any of this in any
of their reports or concerns um
will the shop for instance have a roller
shutter on it to prevent us being woken
up in the middle of the night by windows
being smashed etc because it's it's the
original
30s uh or 40s
um shop front is still in situ
plate glass windows etc is there any is
there going to be any protection
to prevent um burglaries
in the store other than just capturing
what's going to happen on cctv
it was it was publicized on social media
recently the co-op
was um
in in wacom village was actually ram
raided
um
so you know there is crime in the area
and the crime just does seem to be
directed at cigarettes alcohol
um
these kind of things
um but we would like the clarification
of the opening hours especially and
could i just say as well with regards to
selling cheap alcohol as as paula said
earlier people would come and buy it
there because then they wouldn't have to
go to the
co-op is she going to be able to really
compete and offer prices at the co-op
and asda and other places are going to
be are people really going to want to
stop
and buy alcohol there and and
we also believe that although there's no
benches
in in the available area
people do um
you know crowd around the shops and they
have done in the past
um you know late in the year
thank you uh late into the evening so um
does amber want to say something i
should we've got one minute
and score no time
okay um
yeah so people do crowd around those
shops um
and
there's also bins outside the shops and
one bin but it doesn't prevent people
who use the shops at the moment
consuming their goods and then throwing
their litter into our front garden
which you can have drink bottles crisp
packets
um all kinds of consumables that the
bins that's not the bins aren't big
enough really also security lights that
paula talks about having security lights
going on and off all the time all
through the night yeah i know it's helps
with security but there's people that
live around here do we really want
security lights going on and off on the
shop front
and the women's offices complained
several times about the security lights
going off in the past so
you know outdoor
yes
can i ask amber now
for our submission please
hi there um
so
seconding quite a few of those points
and also some others of my own um
the foreground the four court in the
front of the parade uh of shops
does have some congregations sometimes
um especially when it's functioning as a
cafe but that has been you know it's
nice to see um it's nice it's been
used in that way um when it was a cafe
um i am just worried about crowd control
and the fact that i know that when i
walk near the co-op
which is the closest
venue i can think of to compare this
to
i have been very intimidated because
there will be groups of people
especially
kind of on bikes and quite loud
um kids outside the front are of the
co-op who have obviously just purchased
um alcohol or
fizzy drinks things like that um
and
i am very worried that a similar kind of
congregation will happen on that
forecourt out the front
um it is a very
accessible area for that kind of thing i
think it will definitely be used in that
way um and part of that is
um
part of a different shop um which will
probably also be impacted by that um i
am also worried
about the opening hours um i think
something perhaps 11 to five or eleven
till six um being set as
what is allowed would be a lot more
appropriate given the residential area
and also
um given the fact that i know that a lot
of the people who um were saying that
they wanted to use the place as an off
license um and for alcohol
were more about the lunch time having a
beer at lunch um
and
things like that where it's sunnier
weather and i think that could be lovely
um
to have that but
definitely more targeting the lunch time
um
the castle are also there though um
which is a pub
with licensed sell alcohol and they have
um very very effective crowd control
they will bar people and ban people who
have been
who have been problematic or difficult
it's a very safe environment because of
that and i'm worried that the same
measures won't be able to be taken
because um
it's not technically kind of on-site
which is good but they will still use it
as such um the people that are
purchasing from there um i also
frequently um
go by bus at night time um and i have to
get a number eight which means i stop
off
um at the little white crane great way
crown corner and then i walk down past
the parade and i go
down to
um my my house 290 little wakering and
when it comes to passing the pub i
usually i'm a little bit worried but
normally it's okay because i know that
the people there are like i say very
good at crowd control
um and they've sorted out any
altercations very quickly and i haven't
felt too threatened when it comes to the
parade to think that if it could turn
out like the co-op which i think is very
likely with that full court i would be
extremely intimidated um
i already it's quite a long walk and it
is dark
um and it is my only option if i need to
go into town later um for any kind of
improv improv groups or social
um
social events
um or even working late
um that would definitely
uh be of concern
when it comes to the security light
there has been altercations um
outside before
uh which i know have caused significant
kind of stress to certain local
residents um
and i think that is again a very valid
point um
so
they they are my main concerns i think
that the smashed windows and everything
are is very likely
um i am also
just as a as a very brief side note a
little worried about what would be used
to supplement the sale of
the alcohol um such as confectionary
which is very similar to um the direct
neighbor ring business um
so if some type of agreement could be
come to there then i feel like we'd have
a lot better chance of both businesses
surviving um with the alcohol being
there for lunch times and how lovely
that would be um but also
with um
with it mutually working for the for the
local area
with uh without the sale of
similar confectionary items
to the parade
um
that's all i can think of at the moment
but i'm sure there's something else so
if you wouldn't mind just giving me a
moment
um
just having
uh maybe
um
yeah maybe 8 30
latest i don't know um
but
just my just my two cents thank you
thank you
right any members of the committee any
questions i'd like to
get clarification on please
um chair
yes
um
paula
um
okay
to the um
the applicants who the
quick questions you want to
ask
clarification um i'd like to
um say with the the security lights um
paula that that's a statement not a
question for clarification
oh no i've got no questions there right
thank you okay now
i will give
each of the parties
two minutes to make a closing statement
so paula would you like to start
um i'd just like to
say that
i will i am definitely thinking of
putting around the shutters
on the shop and most likely will
and with the light concerning the light
light the security lights
i will have it facing down
not towards the opposite houses
obviously i live opposite as well so
and i've got kids at home and
what else um
yeah the um amber was saying because a
mum works in the shop next door
um about
just sitting alcohol in the afternoon
and
i just thought
if i sold later then
her mum and stan shop
have got different times so it's sort of
even itself out
because she's worried about me taking
their customers and if i were opened
later
i wouldn't be taking their customers
because they'd be sharp
um
crowd control in the forecourt that's
usually in the morning i've lived
opposite the shop for 14 years the um
the school buses stopped there and
said children like um secondary school
children
have to wait for their buses there
not really seen any
crowding in the evening and
also with
all the break-ins i've lived here 14
years
i do remember stands getting broken into
probably the first year i lived here
second year i lived here
i've not seen any other
um crime over at the shop
um
i think noise is
going to happen because we've got
another 120 houses being built
50 foot away
um so there is gonna it's not gonna be
so rural anymore um
cars and
people are just gonna get more in the
area um
120 ounces that's 204
um
well i don't know
yeah i don't expect any noise people
would be buying their goods and leaving
going home and
there's no reason for them to hang
around outside the shop and i think i've
covered everything now
right thank you
yeah
right
i have mr chambers all um amber anything
to
closing statement
um hello i would just say uh to please
consider closing
uh sorry please consider opening hours
to be 11 till 6 to reduce footfall um i
would also
sorry to reduce the
chance of
noise nuisance and
alterations after 6 pm um i would also
say
11 till 6 is not separate
hours to
the neighboring business so that point
doesn't feel
valid in that way
it would not be
mutually
beneficial it wouldn't be a symbiotic um
unless it was something like
five till
11 but at night but then we run into the
issues with
with the residential area so
um that
that is all i believe thank you
right
mr mrs chambers chairman thank you and
so we just basically we've lived in 19
years we will always support the shops
however we feel that we're not um on
hamlet road we don't want a 7-eleven
here we don't think it would benefit the
community whatsoever for the handful of
people that would decide on the few
occasions to go there um it would it
would encourage the people to congregate
kids older kids to hang around it would
encourage people to
um possibly
break in we have we know a few um
instances we live right next door so we
know that there has been trouble and we
just don't want to encourage or risk any
of that um yes there are houses being
built but we are still the village of
wakering and we know that up uh by the
co-op you have a president set you have
the pub ops here you have the chinese
the indian the chip shop you expect it
there down here it's very quiet after
six o'clock at night and that's how it
that's how the the locals will want it
people will soon um uh be very stressed
and upset if we do start getting issues
like other places do where they do have
late opening and selling of alcohol and
i don't think the alcohol is going to be
able to be sold at the price to actually
make it work anyway but that's
irrelevant um but we just want our kids
here we want peaceful quiet life that is
all we want and
the shops opening till 6 pm is what it's
been like for 19 years
thank you very much for listening
okay thank you everybody
right the subcommittee will now adjourn
to deliberate
and make a decision
no party has an obligation to wait for
the outcome hearing following the
adjournment or proceedings
it should be noted that decisions will
be sent in writing to all parties
following the hearing
in any instance if you do wish to
come back in
when we made the decision if you let us
know then we can contact you